THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
TURNING TO OUR OTHER TOP STORY,
TENSIONS RISING BETWEEN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE NOW
THREATENING TRUMP OFFICIALS WITH
CONTEMPT.
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SAID TO VOTE TOMORROW ON A
CONTEMPT CITATION AGAINST
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING THAT
BARR HAND OVER IN UNREDACTED
VERSION OF THE MUELLER REPORT
AND CALLS STARTING FOR TREASURY
SECRETARY STEVEN MNUCHIN TO BE
HELD IN CONTEMPT FOR REFUSING TO
HAND OVER THE PRESIDENT'S TAX
RETURN.
ORDERING DONALD McGAHN NOT TO
COMPLY WITH A CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA.
ALL OF THIS COMES AS A NEW
REPORT SAYS, GET THIS, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE THREATENING TO
WITHHOLD SALARIES OF TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS IF THEY
BLOCK ONGOING COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATIONS.
DESPITE CLAIMS OF OVERAGE FROM
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS ARE
DEFENDING THEIR MULTIPLE PROBES.
>> AS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THIS
WHITE HOUSE AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
I CAN ONLY HOPE THAT AS THE
MONTHS GO BY, THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WAKE UP TO THE FACT THAT
OUR DEMOCRACY IS IN DANGER.
>> OUR LEADER SAYS LET'S MOVE
ON.
IT IS WORDED LIKE RICHARD NIXON
SAYING LET'S MOVE ON AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE INVESTIGATION OF
HIS WRONGDOING.
OF COURSE HE WANTS TO MOVE ON.
HE WANTS TO COVER UP.
>> WE ARE ABOUT GETTING THE
TRUTH TO THE MACON PEOPLE.
THE TRUTH IS WHAT WE WANT TO
BASE OUR DECISIONS ON.
THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
WILLING TO SHARE THAT UNLESS I
HAVE SOMETHING TO HIDE.
>> Dana: AND YOU HAVE THE
MEDIA BLASTING REPUBLICANS FOR
DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT.
>> YOU LOOK AT BARR.
YOU LOOK AT POMPEO.
>> HAS NOW SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH THE MOST DUPLICITOUS
CABINET IN RECENT AMERICAN
HISTORY.
IT'S SHAMEFUL.
>> THEY WANT A 1-PARTY STATE.
THAT'S WHAT THE G.O.P. SEEKS AND
TRUMP WANTS TO BE AN AUTOCRAT
WITH THAT STATE BEHIND HIM.
>> HOW IS IT THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, YOUR COLLEAGUES, CAN
STAND BY THIS MAN WHEN HE'S
INVOLVED IN THIS WAY WITH RUSSI
RUSSIA?
I SAID THAT I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ANY OF THOSE FLAG PINS ON
REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T STAND UP
AGAINST THE SKY FOR RUSSIAN
MEDDLING IN OTHER THINGS.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH HE'S
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> Shepard: WHERE TO EVEN
BEGIN?
GREG GUTFELD, LET'S GO TO YOU.
McCONNELL SPOKE TODAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME, GIVE A LONG SPEECH
IN SAID CASE CLOSED.
IT WAS FUNNY TO WATCH
CHUCK SCHUMER MOVE      TO SAY -
>> Greg: MoveOn.org.
THE DEMS ARE DESPERATE.
THEY ARE LIKE A TINY ARMY FACED
WITH A DWINDLING PATCH OF TURF
TO DEFEND.
REMEMBER HOW BIG THE THREAT WAS
A PUBLISHER'S AGO?
TRUMP WAS INSANE, RACIST,
THREATS OF WORLD SAFETY AND THE
ECONOMY.
NOW YOU HAVE THE GREATEST
ECONOMY IN 50 YEARS, LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE?
WHAT ARE THEY CLINGING TO?
TAX RETURNS AND THEIR FEELINGS
ARE HURT OVER THE MUELLER REPORT
WHICH THEY ASKED FOR.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SCREAM ABOUT
COVER-UP AND CONSPIRACY, STICK
TO STUFF LIKE JFK OR SPACE
ALIENS.
NOT SOMETHING PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO CALL IT A
COVER-UP WHEN SOMETHING IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
IT REMINDS ME OF GROWING UP
WATCHING THE
HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS PLAY THE
WASHINGTON GENERALS.
TRUMP IS THE
HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS AND THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS BY THE
WASHINGTON GENERALS.
THEY CAN ONLY RESPOND HELPLESSLY
AGAINST THE STRANGE PHENOMENON.
THEY NEVER ADJUST OR ADAPT TO
PLAY AGAINST THE
HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS BECAUSE
THEY JUST LOSE EVERY TIME.
I IMAGINE A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
DEMANDED YOU ADHERE TO THEIR
DELUSIONS OR THEY WILL PUNISH
YOU.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NO
NOW.
THE MEDIA, THE VIEW, MORNING
WHAT'S HIS FACE, THEY BELONG TO
A BASICALLY A PAGAN RELIGION IN
WHICH THEY ADHERE TO THEM KIND
OF EMOTIONAL BELIEF THAT GOES
AGAINST ALL THE FACTS, LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG MINORITIES,
WOMEN, GDP, STOCK MARKET MOVING
UP EVEN THOUGH IT DROPS NOW AND
THEN.
PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
THERE PAGAN CULT RELIGION HAS
BEEN TELLING EVERYBODY THE WORLD
IS GOING TO HELL.
>> Dana: SPEAKER PELOSI SAID
TRUMP IS TRYING TO GOAD US INTO
IMPEACHING HIM.
SHE CLEARLY DOESN'T WANT TO DO
IT BUT YOU MIGHT GET PUSHED INTO
IT.
I AM READING HERE THAT INTERIOR
COMMERCE AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILA
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILE
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILT
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILR
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILS
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILL
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILR
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILE
STAFF, THEY ARE WARNED THEY WILS
WITHHELD IF THEY BLOCK ONGOING
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATIONS.
IN A LOT OF THESE DISPUTES, I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
THAT IN BENGHAZI.
>> Jesse: BRASS KNUCKLE
TACTICS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE THE DEMOCRATS
CREDITS.
WHY CAN'T WE WITHHOLD THEIR
SALARIES?
I THINK THAT SHOULD BE AN OPTION
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LIED FOR TWO
YEARS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD WITHHOLD
TRUMP --
OH, WAIT.
HE DOES ISN'T TAKE ONE.
>> Jesse: HE IS DONATING IT.
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING, NADLER
IS LIKE A PEEPING TOM.
IT'S GOTTEN CREEPY.
HE'S PEERING THROUGH THE
WINDOWS, LOOKING AT PEOPLE'S
DIARIES, RUMMAGING THROUGH
GARBAGE.
HE LOOKS WEIRD.
RIGHT NOW MUELLER SPENT TWO
YEARS LOOKING FOR SOMETHING,
DIDN'T FIND A CRIME.
THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
JUST AS THEY CAN'T ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WITHOUT
COLLUSION, THE SCANDAL IS NOT
SEXY.
YOU DON'T HAVE DEAD BODIES.
OR HAVE VIDEO.
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING COMPELLING.
>> Dana: CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
>> Jesse: CONTEMPT, ATTEMPTED
OBSTRUCTION, EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY
DON'T HAVE THE APPETITE FOR THAT
TYPE OF SCANDAL.
THEY CAN ONLY DIGEST SO MUCH.
I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW WHO DONALD McGAHN
IS.
IF I ASKED TEN PEOPLE WHO
WILLIAM BARR IS, LESS THAN HALF
WOULD KNOW WHO HE HAS.
WE HAVE A NEW Q POLL,
QUINNIPIAC, JUAN.
THE PUBLIC OPPOSES IMPEACHMENT
BY 37-POINT MARGIN.
70 FOR THAT OF INDEPENDENTS ARE
AGAINST THE IDEA BUT THE
DEMOCRAT BASE WANT THAT SO THEY
NEED ANOTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS SO THEY HAVE TO COOK UP A
NEW CRIME AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION FOUND NO CRIME.
>> Dana: THERE WAS ANOTHER NEW
POLL, JUAN.
I'M KIDDING.
I WOULD NEVER DO THAT TO YOU.
I GALLUP POLL SHOWS HE'S MORE
POPULAR THAN EVER BEFORE.
THIS IS THE NUMBER, 46%.
I THINK THIS IS WHERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS THIS TIME IN
HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> Juan: YEAH, WENT OVER THIS
YESTERDAY.
>> Dana: SORRY.
GREG.
>> Greg: WE WERE HERE
YESTERDAY.
>> Juan: IT'S GOOD NEWS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S STILL UNDERWATER
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHO IS
MOVING IN THOSE POLES.
WHAT WE SEE IS INDEPENDENTS
AREN'T MOVING.
SLIGHT MOVEMENT AMONG DEMOCRATS.
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRATS --
THEY DID.
THEY WENT UP FROM 31 TO 39.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT.
THE POINT IS WHEN YOU HAVE ONE
GREG IS TALKING ABOUT, WHO WON
THE LAST ELECTION IN TERMS OF
POPULAR VOTE?
I THINK IT WAS A DEMOCRAT.
RIGHT NOW MOST AMERICANS DON'T
APPROVE OF TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: MORE POPULAR THAN
OBAMA AT THE TIME.
>> Juan: EVEN WITH THE ECONOMY
UP THERE, THIS GUY CAN'T GET A
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS TO APPROVE
OF HIS CONDUCT.
>> Dana: 46 IS HIGHER THAN
WHAT HILLARY AND TRUMP WERE AS
CANDIDATES.
NEITHER OF THEM BROKE 43 I DON'T
THINK.
>> Dagen: AND HIS APPROVAL
RATING ON THE ECONOMY IS MUCH
HIGHER BECAUSE AGAIN THIS
COUNTRY IS SO PROSPEROUS RIGHT
NOW AND WAGES ARE GROWING.
WE CAN GET INTO THIS LATER.
WAGES ARE GROWING FASTER FOR
PRODUCTION WORKERS, MINING OR
RETAIL, YOUR WAGES ARE GROWING
FASTER THAN SUPERVISORY JOBS.
IT CLOSES THE WEALTH GAP.
>> Juan: FROM A LOW LEVEL.
>> Dana: ISN'T THAT WHAT WE
WANT TO DO?
>> Dagen: WAGES ARE GROWING
THE FASTEST PACE IN A DECADE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING
PRESIDENT OBAMA COULD EVER DO.
DECADES.
I WANT TO BRING UP ONE THING,
YOU ARE BROUGHT UP HILLARY.
HILLARY!
WE ARE THANKFUL SHE'S NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WE HAVE TO LISTEN TO THAT EVERY
DAY.
IN TERMS OF THE TV TALK SHOW
HOST, HOW CLOSE ARE WE TO THEM
HAVING REAGAN McNEIL MOMENT.
THEY ARE SO ENRAGED WITH BILE.
THEY WILL UNDERSTAND HOW WE FEEL
HAVING TO WATCH THESE CLIPS
EVERY DAY.
>> Juan: , I FOLLOW UP ON THE
WHOLE BUSINESS ABOUT THE WAR.
I THINK THERE'S A BIG WAR GOING
ON BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CONGRESS.
THESE DOCUMENTS.
I THINK, IT'S VERY INTERESTING
WHETHER PEOPLE KNOW WHO DONALD
McGAHN IS OR NOT, OBVIOUSLY
WAS THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE THAT
WAS BROUGHT IN BY MUELLER AND
APPARENTLY HE SAID TO MUELLER
THAT TRUMP HAD --
BUTTON NOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS
SAYING WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET
YOU HAVE THE DOCUMENTS THAT
MCGANN HAD ANYTHING TO RESOLVE
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE BECAUSE SOME
OF THIS IS, AS YOU POINT OUT,
ALREADY IN THE REPORT THAT'S
LARGELY BEEN MADE PUBLIC.
SOME OF IT IS REDACTED.
SOME OF THE UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS
HAVE BEEN KEPT SECRET BUT DONALD
McGAHN IS THERE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GO ONTO
GONNA CLAIM SOMETHING LIKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THE LOGIC DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE PRESIDENT IS
HIDING SOMETHING.
HE'S ACTING LIKE A GUILTY MAN.
>> Dana: IT'S HARD TO RUN FOR
REELECTION SAYING THAT YOU RAN
FOR TWO YEARS ON THIS ISSUE.
>> Greg: I'M EXCITED THAT CNN
IS GOING TO HAVE A JAMES COMEY
TOWN HALL.
WHY'S THAT NECESSARY?
WHY WOULD YOU HAVE A TOWN HALL
WITH JAMES COMEY?
YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP IT ALIVE.
THE PROFIT MOTIVE FOR CNN AND
MSNBC IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
CONFLICT.
BECAUSE THEY BETRAY THEIR
AUDIENCE WITH THEIR LIE OF
COLLUSION, THEY HAVE TO -- IT'S
LIKE THEY ARE AT A BAR RUNNING
OUT OF BOOZE SO THEY HAVE
WATERED DOWN BOOZE SO COMEY IS
THERE WATERED-DOWN BOOZE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CONGRESS.
IT'S NOT A BATTLE BETWEEN
CONGRESS AND TRUMP.
IT'S THE POLARITY BETWEEN MEDIA
AND AMERICA.
THE MEDIA IS SO UPSET THIS
NARRATIVE COLLAPSED.